depuis quelques semaines le téléphone
sonne davantage et les textos sont plus
insistants dans ce cabinet de courtage
hypothécaire ah bah c'est exactement là
que ça fait mal actuellement là c'est
sûr l'augmentation du paiement
hypothécaire sur le budget avec cette
hausse de filet du taux directeur
Philippe Simard doit bien souvent
rassurer les clients qui ont vu leur
budget resserrer on pouvait s'attendre
un petit peu à des hausses du taux
directeur là mais de cet ordre là ça le
surpris vraiment tout le monde ce matin
la Banque du Canada a aussi d'un demi
point pourcentage sont au directeur qui
est maintenant à 4 et un quart pour cent
dans un des cycles aussi les plus
importantes de son histoire l'impact
direct il en coûtera donc plus cher pour
les emprunteurs prenons par exemple une
hypothèque de 300000 dollars au début de
l'année avec un taux variable de 2%,
vous pouviez vous attendre à payer 1270
dollars mensuellement mais avec un taux
à 5%, il en coûtera plus de 1700 dollars
une hausse de 500 dollars ces gens là
qui commencent à savoir des appels dans
leur banque parce que
il atteigne un point où est-ce que à
certains moments il y a des gens qui
payent plus du tout de capital sur leur
prêt hypothécaire et là évidemment il y
a des actions qui doivent être portées
sur leur hypothèque avec l'inflation qui
était de 6,9 % en octobre cette banque
alimentaire a remarqué une hausse la
demande on est un petit peu le
thermomètre non officiel la situation
économique parce que nous sommes la
première porte d'entrée pour les gens
qui sont en situation de précarité il
m'aurait rencontré espère quant à eux
avoir un répit vraiment je trouve ça en
vrai d'étouffer les gens là ça monte
partout de tout le bord du côté on en a
pas mal jusque là de tout mais en tant
que travailleur on n'arrive pas à quand
le retour de la baisse des taux
d'intérêt la Banque du Canada constate
que l'inflation est encore trop élevée
mais ouvre la porte à la fin d'un cycle
et quand est-ce économique risque de se
corser encore davantage en 2023 avec une
possible récession qui risque d'avoir
encore plus d'impact sur le portefeuille
des ménages ici Olivier Bourguet au
Canada à Montréal